here with insight on these stories and
more is CBS News political director
Caitlyn Conant Caitlyn good morning good
morning thanks for having me Anthony
thanks for being here let's let's start
with with what chip alluded to a lot of
you know we're less than 20 days away
from the midterms now the president is
banging the drum on the immigration
issue which is bread and butter with his
base so that's sort of the direction the
Republicans seem to be taking how are
the Democrats responding to this well
you know there's no question as you said
that for the Republicans this is a top
issue or the top issue to them so Donald
Trump is heading into states where
Democrats are on the defense they're
trying to hold on to their Senate seats
in ten states where he won in 2016 so
he's going in and trying to convince his
voters that if you don't hold on to a
Republican majority and we don't keep
this that unfortunately the Democrats
are going to come in and he's trying to
scare them and say you know they will
have open border policies they will call
to abolish ice and the Democrats are
trying to say well we're here we want to
have compromise immigration on or
compromise policy on immigration so
there are two conflicting messages
obviously Anthony mentioned the twenty
days so the election have we gotten any
indication and in these midterms as to
where things may sway the way that they
may sway well I think a lot remains to
be seen and a lot can happen in the
final weeks but what I will tell you is
that while we talk about the Trump
tweets of the day and whatever the
latest scandal is the campaign's on both
the Republican and the Democratic side
have been relatively consistent and they
have been talking about pocketbook
issues health care and economy remain
the top issues for voters and you have
Republicans running on basically a
record of results and saying the economy
is great if you want to keep that vote
for Republicans and the Democrats will
just be the party of resistance I mean
while the Democrats are running on
health care and they're saying you know
if you elect Republicans to back to the
Congress they are going to take away
coverage for pre-existing conditions
it's going to hurt you and your loved
ones who are suffering it's their
message has been very consistent overall
yeah are there any races in any of these
swing states that really are the
barometer to what will happen come
November 6 well there are two trends
that I'm specifically looking at one is
women voters in the suburbs and so one
area where both the Republic
some Democrats say it could be a
bellwether that we'll be able to tell
who's gonna take back control of the
house on election night is Minnesota
you've got the Twin Cities suburbs
they're in st. Paul Minneapolis and
you've got two Republican Congressman
Jason Lewis and Eric Paulsen who are
trying to hold on to their seats and
then another place is deep red states
where there's a big question of
enthusiasm and the Democrats seemed to
be have an edge in an enthusiasm gap but
the question is whether that enthusiasm
actually translates to people showing up
to the polls so you have Stacey Abrams
who's a Democrat running for governor in
Georgia and she is going around
canvassing the state talking to every
voter or not taking anyone for granted
and then on the Senate side the same
thing you've got better o'rourke in
Texas who is really hoping that he can
talk to voters who haven't showed up in
the polls the last few cycles and that
they'll go and vote for vote for them
this fall right
I do CBS News poll Katelyn just got
released Friday and one of the questions
was regarding how voters process the
last year of politics what do we see in
that well we saw that voters hopefully
are watching us they're the same
conversations we are and really like
talking about politics and what the
Democrats and Republicans are hoping is
that that engagement that enthusiasm
actually translates to people showing up
at the polls this fall
all right Katelyn Konan thank you so
much for being with us this morning
thank you for having me